hey watch out if you don't want spoilers
turn this video off now maybe watch it
later after you see the movie
i'm here with tom menino to talk about
the best and worst things
we saw in black widow nina what are the
best
and worst things you saw in black widow
thanks brian um well my gut answer is
just to say florence pugh
because i love her i thought she was
really good in this movie so that's like
i mean i could be flip and just say
florence pugh because she's really good
as yelena and as i'm sure we'll discuss
i think she probably has a future within
the mcu as well
and her just really deadpan monotonous
dry wit was a welcome addition but i
also feel like i need to say
the whole casting of the family was very
good david harbor was really funny
alexi was a great addition and i loved
seeing rachel vice
in something that's not you know an
oscar baby
super dramatic biopic yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it was nice to see you know daniel
craig's main squeeze having some fun
and i love the dynamic and the chemistry
between all four of the
you know found family um assassins
now that you mentioned rachel vice
having fun it just reminds me that one
of her first
big roles was in the mummy where she
plays
yeah right that's true yeah like what
was it 1930s era
like yeah like she had the eyebrows and
the makeup and everything and she just
inhabited this great old-timey film role
yeah and she has a great
a great bunch of fun she's doing
pratfalls she's doing action
you know it's all happening and so yeah
now that you mention it it's like this
is the kind of stuff that she
kind of came into hollywood doing and
she did a great job here too yeah i
totally agree the cast was
fantastic yeah and like i feel like when
you let an actress like that have fun
and another
actually another rachel but i feel like
this is true as mcadams where once you
let her just enjoy herself on screen she
really lights up and she makes the whole
movie better
hopefully she'll do some more
interesting things and doctors and
doctor
exactly my dog has really strong
feelings about this clearly
yeah i just i know that we get off topic
like really easily but why don't we just
really quick i'll name our top 20
favorite rachel's just off the top
anyway i loved the chemistry between the
family i thought
just the smaller moments of the film i
mean we talked about this and what we
wanted to see in black widow right and i
got a lot of that
i got a lot of that emotional core i got
a real some really fun scenes between
the family members
and then i also got exactly what i
didn't want which was
something really dumb and marvelly and
it was the floating
red room station which is so stupid
like why i hate i did not i just was
like they needed a dumb giant fx thing
to put like it could have been on the
ground it could have been underground it
could have been literally anywhere and
they were like let's make it a
spacecraft
for or or a spacecraft adjacent thing i
don't know a helicopter wasn't actually
it was stupid brian okay so i stand by
it
i'm gonna i'm gonna jump off your worst
into
i don't necessarily agree that that the
floating red room was the worst part i
okay didn't mind it i thought that was
fine i had no problem with it my problem
was more with
the villain whose name i have already
forgotten
played by ray winston winstone winston
we'll go with winston
oh my god i forgot it too and i
rewatched the movie this morning he's
not a great villain because i don't
really know what he did
or what he wanted or what power he had
like he's
he had that big monologue at the end
where he's like i have black widows
all over the world you know like that's
my that's my bad impression thank you
he has black widows all over the world
and he
see i didn't play that part that's like
um but uh he
he he's talking about the conference
he's got
he's got all these black widows all over
the world and he's talking about how he
has all this power
but it's never clear what that power is
how he actually wields it what the
consequences are
of him continuing to wield it and i feel
like it's reach
kind of exceeded its grasp there where
it's trying to make him a big
bad marvel global villain but at the end
of the day he's just kind of like
a very generic evil
jerk with no clear but i feel like they
did explain what power he had where he's
like i have
sleeper agents all over the world who
can do whatever i want whenever i want
it and yeah they explain it but like
but to what end like like they don't
show it they just he just
says sure he's just like oh did you know
i have assassins all over the world and
we're like
oh interesting and then the movie goes
well now you don't
so it's just in that vein just quickly i
also found the taskmaster reveal really
underwhelming having to do with the
villain
i didn't mind that i was i was you know
we all predicted that it was going to be
rachel vice
and i don't know i don't think any of us
said that out loud
potential spoiler alert she predicts
that it's going to be
rachel vice's character of course it's
going to be rachel
i was happy to see that it wasn't i was
true
and i i didn't mind the reveal i thought
see i thought that worked really well
because overall this is what
this is one of the things i really liked
about the movie which is that this is a
movie that's about something
for one sure not maybe not for once but
you know what i mean like this has a
very
clear theme going from start to finish
where
this is about kind of confronting your
trauma um
from your past and trying to resolve it
trying to accept it come to grips with
it
and and resolve it and move on and so
the reveal
that um that taskmaster was actually
the little girl that natasha thought she
had murdered in her attempt to get out
right doing something to to fix her her
trauma
means exiting defecting but she had to
kill this girl to do it and then we find
out that the girl is alive but this
you know like it all works right now
you've you've kind of turned me around
in it to be honest because like
no you did this that's not i'm not uh
not being sarcastic like
i guess i didn't think about it in the
framework of the of the overarching
message of the movie's approach to
how you handle drama i just think at the
time i was like well i don't
really know who this person is but i
think upon a re-watch
or something like that i think you're
right it does tie into the theme of the
movie really well
i mean it's obviously yeah go ahead i'm
a little bit disappointed
to hear that you don't think that the
other marvel movies have messages i mean
i think like they've always been very
socially
conscious and had like kind of a
political undertone to them it feels
like
iron man 2 uh they kind of had that
message about like drones are bad
and then like age of ultron they had
that message about how you don't want to
build drones because they're bad and
then
the captain america and the winter
soldier there was that whole plot line
about how
drones aren't very good and shouldn't be
employed
it's always been kind of a rainbow of
messages
to me you know i hadn't considered that
and i appreciate you pointing that out
um the drone-centric messaging of the
mcu was there a similar
was was there a similar theme at work in
guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 about drones they're fun to kill i
think that was part of it
but i i don't recall whereas in this one
it was very much about how
you shouldn't take women and turn them
into drones you shouldn't take women
and turn them into drones that's true i
hadn't even considered that theme
so yeah like that's exciting
i'm the mr rogers of a generation that's
what the tie is all about you should be
wearing a sweater
next time it's 112 degrees here brian oh
yeah that's right
sorry very much apologies i shouldn't
have laughed at that
no so i i feel like overall yeah that
was one of my best things that it had a
really great arc it had a great theme
but i feel like the villain the ultimate
villain reveal
for me very much fell flat it was super
forgettable
the stakes were the stakes were high
enough with we have to free all these
women
i have to you know deal with my family
and figure this out i have to kill this
guy
it would have been enough to kill a bad
guy who was abducting women
and turning them into assassins i think
for me it would have been more
interesting if he was
not this all powerful secret
you know guy and he was more explicitly
like
i have these assassins all over the
world and i sell them to the highest
bidder
you know influence geopolitical events
and i don't care what happens as long as
i get my money and get to live in my
floating
secret base you know like all of those
things i think would have made for a
more interesting
you know an interesting explanation and
then natasha's just like well that ends
now and i'm gonna
like the stakes were high enough where
she needs to kill this guy she needs to
shop this program and free these women
making it this secret world
spider web pun intended of black widows
um for me doesn't s it didn't feel
necessary so it kind of felt a little
tacked on
um my other least favorite
thing was the song under the opening
credits the
awful cover of smells like team spirit
tom yeah
did you want to say something about that
just like four or five paragraphs
go ahead totally fine
it was uh it really bummed me out to
hear that cover
it smells like teen spirit i mean i'm
not gonna pull some kind of old man card
and say
oh that song should be left alone i
don't care about any of that like
it's a good song it's a fine song but
when that song started playing i could
not
help but think how lame and and silly it
was
thankfully once it was over the movie
kicked into gear and i
really enjoyed pretty much everything
that came after it overall i really
liked this movie but
yeah yeah that definitely didn't
bode well i was gonna say a wait what a
way to kick it off
right because we're we're all aging
uh uh right in front of everybody's eyes
we all existed during the 90s right
we remember what it was like to pretend
that things had depth so that people
would like us more
but you're right it smells like tea
spirit
if i've got to pretend for one more day
that the lyrics to that song have
any emotional depth to them at all i am
going to burn
every landsat and factory outlet to the
ground i think that we have trust in
this country with flannel for far too
long and look at what we have done with
it
hey i'm you're part of the problem brian
solution i like this shirt this is one
of my favorite shirts
um no you're right though like kurt
cobain has famously said that he doesn't
really put much into his lyrics he just
looks at your stuff that
that rhymes and it sounds good yeah i
know surprise
you're saying that the moment where he
thought that mosquito and libido sound
pretty similar that didn't
carry a lot of there's only one good
on-screen use of smells like teen spirit
and it is during
the can can dance in moulin rouge that's
it
that's it i don't know i don't make the
rules but also i make the rules
okay that's fantastic this is bad news
tom what were your best and worst
moments from black widow
and let me tell you brian i'm glad you
asked because i think that we can all
agree
uh i haven't been around for a minute
that
trying to find the opinions of a 30 year
old white man on what scarlett johansson
is doing professionally on the internet
is like trying to find water in the
desert so
it's good that he came to me with these
questions
colin jost wasn't available tom so we
had to call you
thank you very much i bring half the
charisma and four times the forehead
so what we uh
i agree with a lot of what you guys said
i i thought the cast was terrific i
thought
that family dinner scene it almost felt
like taking a breath for the first time
in the movie yeah everything was
so dour and then i also loved just
quickly when rachel vice is like stop
slouching
you're slouching yeah no that is what
every mother says to her
child spot on like they nailed that
whole dynamic
that was really charming i thought that
was like i thought
it was maybe a little hasty of the main
characters to assume
that that the bad guy was that and i
agree with you about the bad guy
although
i i do think that he brought roughly the
same
energy as john belushi and blues
brothers when he asks how much for the
little girl
and like that was that was as far as
they got right in that guy
i thought it was hasty for the maybe
short-sighted for them to assume that he
died in that explosion since throughout
the entire movie explosions were treated
like
this sort of a roadblock more than
anything like it's just this brief
inconvenience that keeps happening to
people
they uh yeah florence pugh's character
there at the end like she just
stands right next to an exploding engine
and rides that wave right
right down to the ground that lonely
island cool guys don't video
cool guys don't look at explosions is
exactly correct
almost exactly yeah except i think she
was staring it right down the barrel too
and then like uh natasha's car gets
exploded like twice in a row
so that was a little bit funky i'm not
gonna whine about taskmaster it would be
cool to see
like comic book accurate taskmaster but
like the way that they did all the fight
choreography with that character that
was
terrific i thought the fight
choreography across the board was really
good
it's pretty neat like i really enjoyed
watching the fights they didn't feel
as like sky laser beamy as marvel tends
to
right i felt like the camera work was
very like tight and focused
and it was and the fights looked and and
also like good job on the sound editing
like every punch sounded good
how great was that car chase in really
good budapest oh my god i was laughing
like a maniac
with all the door maneuvers she does
yeah
that was a great that was a great scene
brings up another thing because like
uh they i feel like they didn't lean too
hard into needing to
define everything that they pointed out
about this character like we
didn't get the half hour flashback
sequence to budapest
and i'm really comfortable with that
lately let some of it be head canon
it's fine yeah right they explained it
but they didn't like
make it beat us over the head with us
yeah it was it was really well done
overall
i yeah no very much like not not solo
which was what i was worried about
i feel like close quarantine david
harbor trying to fit into his pants
is what we all needed to see yeah
yeah and just being convinced that he
looks exactly fine
i love david harper through this whole
thing really
like it a little bit bummed me out that
he didn't get a better hellboy because i
think he would have done some great
stuff with that character
he's fantastic he was hilarious
everything he did on screen like i
made me laugh he was great yeah and then
my only other nitpick is just that
there's all this really incongruous
technology stuff that goes on in mcu
movies and it's really it's fun it's
like we've got a flying helicarrier base
that nobody can pick up on radar but
the best way that we have to mark our
cut for a uh
for brain surgery is still just a magic
mark magic marker yeah
yeah it was like i i had the same thing
in civil war
when uh when when roadie gets shot out
of the sky and then they take us to a
hospital to get an mri and i think
vision is like standing there watching
this happen
this living machine who's he's like no i
can't do a leg scan it's fine
just put him in the big magnet should
vision be anywhere near an mri should he
be standing near them
he would definitely interfere with a
giant magnet that's
very much the same yep yeah also how did
we feel about
like the so i am a sucker for any movie
that features someone pulling off
a face that's not their face i love that
it's such a good it's a gimmick
that gets me every impossible time
yes and there were strong americans
vibes one of my favorite shows
yeah so yeah i liked that reveal that
rachel vice and scarlett jones and
switched places
it was great it was well done once once
it happened you're just like
oh okay yeah yeah it and it wasn't some
dumb overly convoluted explanation it
was just like no they just planned it
that's it
it was very straightforward i liked that
it was managed to do like a flashback
heist explanation thing without making
it seem trite or stupid yeah
very brief yeah oh it was nicely done
but on the flip side let's talk about
that post-credits scene
which in my opinion
i didn't know i loved it okay
i don't care about that at all i thought
it was great when she went to natasha's
i mean not great that she went to her
grave but i thought that the scene up to
that point was
was good it was touching it's affecting
i'm a little annoyed that we got a
pretty good movie for for black widow
and now she's dead so that bums me out
i hate that but whatever like we'll put
that aside but then
the contestants there we're still not
100 sure what she does
who she is we know that florence pugh's
character elena works for her in some
capacity i guess as an assassin
and then she says here's your next
target the person who
killed who got your sister killed or
killed your sister and it's a picture of
hawkeye
and immediately i'm like oh okay so
elena and hawkeye will fight and then
they'll be friends
like yeah there's nothing that's going
to happen that really will surprise me
that much because
i wouldn't lose any sleep if she
actually killed him but you're probably
right i'm just saying like it's
well yeah i mean if that if that
happened that would be really shocking
but i
yeah i would that's not being used
money so like for me a lot of the people
this isn't seasons one through three of
game of thrones they don't just kill
people with abandon
most most of the other post-credits
scenes in throughout the mcu's history
have all kind of been
really interesting teasers really great
setups for
characters we haven't met or events that
we're really excited about and
interested in but this is like
hey check out this guy he's getting his
own show on disney plus soon
you're gonna be in it and it's like cut
to black
okay yeah so that's my that's my feeling
but clearly i'm not the only one who
thought that
isn't that what the post-credits scenes
have kind of been doing for
the last year yeah i mean one of them
was sam jackson being like
do you want to join the avengers and
then yeah but that one
came out called the avengers now wait a
second though nina that was before
we'd ever seen anything like the
avengers before like that was true that
was a
it was a true long stone account 1997
avengers
and ray fines oh my god i forgot and i
want to say sean connery in a giant
teddy bear
i'm not saying that all of those credit
scenes are great i'm saying that
a lot of them tend to tease things in
interesting
exciting ways like uh you know i know a
guy right like they've got
like thanos being like i'll do it myself
thanos i'll do it yeah exactly
big teases where you're like oh this
hooks into this big storyline
or i guess uh fury and maria
disappearing and the beeper having them
captain marvel captain marvel and then
captain marvel coming through at the end
of uh
at the end of her movie and so like the
way that they teased
that was the thing that was coming up
i don't understand that the i don't
understand the complaint i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry i'm not i'm saying that i'm
saying that those teasers in the
previous movies i felt like
hinted at large interesting new
characters or ideas whereas this is
this is hey check out this character all
the viewers remember from the other
movies
you're gonna fight and then you'll be
friends counterpoint is it
a bad reveal because it involves one of
the least interesting mcu
characters maybe i just feel like
there's nothing there for me to sink my
teeth into it's just
it seems like about buckeye period i'm
just like okay
it seems like it's a work-life balance
you'll fight
for a lot of other heroes to do that
he's raising a
family he married linda carlini what
else do you want i will give him
kudos for marrying linda cardellini
that's what i get we all
dreamed of marrying linda cardellini who
goes without saying
but anyway i'm going to shut up i'm i'm
the only person who
it's lindsay i'm the only person who
didn't who didn't really get much out of
that post-credits scene what but what
did you guys think you you obviously
liked it
tom you go ahead i i got nothing out of
it
it didn't really do anything for me i
yeah
it does bother me that like the the
biggest hook that a lot of these things
have is
just wait until next time man spend
another 12
and you're gonna have an even better
time in six months like
yeah did you like this wait till this
happens yeah you know
that was like that was my biggest
problem with uh with age of ultron when
it came out was that like at the time
it didn't really feel like a story as
much as it felt like
a bunch of ten minute vignettes
explaining what you could expect in the
next few movies
sure and so yeah i i don't know it's
good advertising i guess
uh i i don't know i feel like we've kind
of
the mcu is is running out of uh great
big avengers e characters
for us to care about
i would have been interested so sorry
one last thing i was just going to say i
would have been interested if it teased
xiangxi
if it teased the eternals if it is the
new spiderman movie but instead of
teased
a picture of hawkeye fair it's like you
the oscars ended with a picture of
anthony hopkins recently so climbing on
pictures of things
very 2021-5 i'm just i guess that's a
good um
but anyway what were you going to say
nina no my question was going to be do
you think
that the excitement was like
you know me having a distaste for
hawkeye aside do you think that the
excitement was also any excitement was
taken out of it because we have seen
the contessa already in a thing we were
supposed to see later so like this was
supposed to be her marvel
debut so it was supposed i mean that
would have been a bigger surprise right
if you like hear somebody blowing their
nose and you look over and it's elaine
from seinfeld
if anything i think this worked better
because i
had more context as to who she is and
that's sure
a shady person but if she had shown up
in black widow and i'd seen that first
i'd be like what i'd be even more
confused i'd be even
more kind of like curious as to what's
going on i'm just wondering if that like
you know that would have been everyone
knows who that actor is so it would have
been like a reveal
and now we're just like oh we know that
she's shady because of everything she
did in cap
and falcon the winter soldier yeah i
don't know
it left me left me feeling the the the
post credit scene for me
usually the post credit scenes were
always kind of exciting to me and then
this time i was just kind of like
you know what i would love to see is
like the uh the the documentary like in
universe that must have come out where
all of the adventures just went into
great detail about everything that
happened while they were fighting thanos
because i don't understand how she
played
yeah when she was like she was a hero
yeah who did who did hawkeye tell
like yeah no so we were on purple planet
right and then we run into the ghost
of a dude from the 40s and then one of
us has to die or there's no magic stone
so uh anyway even though they've got a
drawer full of them at the tva
headquarters my friend dropped off
as she as she flew as natasha flew away
at the very end
in that ship i said to myself and then
she died on another planet
and it's just kind of one of those
things where you know
again i i briefly touched on this it's
just kind of like one of those things
where
if if black widow were going to get her
own franchise this would be like hey
this was a pretty good first black widow
movie can't wait to see the next one
because i bet it's going to be even more
action-packed
and full of cool spy stuff oh oh oh no
well and that's not the pandemic's fault
that's marvel's fault for not
exactly that a black widow movie would
do well like years ago
yeah so this this definitely bums me out
and it also
really reduces a lot of the tension
during some scenes i mean
again not that you ever think that black
widow is going to die during this movie
just you know outside of any context but
knowing that she has to live long enough
to die in a later movie
it really reduces the tension when she's
doing that if any of the other
characters die it won't affect anything
that happens
because we know the future already
that's always the problem with a prequel
or an
interqual or whatever you want to call
this so that's definitely one of those
songs
yeah yeah it just rolls off the tongue
integra yeah
yeah mid pull yeah mid cool that's what
you take between dayquil and nyquiling
get you bye for watching please hit like
and subscribe so you don't miss a single
[Music]
video